police say it was racial hatred not
terrorism that there was a likely motive
behind a killing spree in Fresno
California officers arrested 39-year old
Corey Ali Mohammed they say that he shot
and killed three people all of them
white men and he was planning to shoot
more people before he surrendered
yesterday Carter Evans is in Fresno with
the latest on this investigation Carter
good morning good morning police say
this all happened in less than two
minutes with one man dying in the
parking lot of the Catholic Charities
organization right here you can see
there's already a small memorial set up
police say the gunmen ran right down the
street here seemingly opening fire at
random they say he's not a terrorist
instead he's a man motivated by hate the
shots rang out late Tuesday morning 16
rounds shot in four separate locations
in approximately 90 seconds this is the
man in custody
Cory Ali Mohammed police say he first
opened fire at around 10:45 a.m.
shooting a passenger in a truck who
later died he walked around a corner
fired at another man but missed he then
claimed his second victim reloaded and
reached to Catholic Charities parking
lot where a third man was shot and kill
all were white males ranging in age from
34 to 58 this cell phone video appears
to show Muhammad opening fire this woman
saw people trying to help the third
victim they tried to you know do CPR and
then when she thought you know made sure
that he has a pulse there were nothing
police gave chase in Mohammed surrender
they say he shouted god is great in
Arabic we do not believe based on the
information we have today that this is a
terrorist related crime we believe it is
a hate crime you but not what to destroy
the white business world but we still do
police say Muhammad recorded videos
professing anti-white views earlier
Tuesday they issued a wanted bulletin
for Muhammad in connection with the
shooting death of a white security guard
last week he saw that media release and
as a result he made a decision to
himself that he was not going to go
to jail for shooting a security guard
that he was going to kill as many people
as he could and that's what he set out
to do well police say Mohammed also
pointed his revolver at two women with a
four-year-old child but those women were
latina and Mohammed did not open fire
Norah all right Carter thank you